so welcome everybody to the first
installment of the Sullivan County
Republican Committee speakers forums
anybody hear about some controversy okay
well just for the record okay
the Progressive Socialist Warriors are
under the impression that tonight's
event has been canceled it is Friday
October 4th and Robert Spencer is
presenting in Sullivan County we will
not stand idly by and let our
constitutional rights be trampled upon
and as I said to the valley new's today
when they called me for a quote people
had better wake up and people had better
stand up and defend Liberty today the
Sullivan County Republican committees
First Amendment rights were under attack
tomorrow it could be yours and who's
going to be left to fight for you who's
gonna be left to speak up for you I for
one am not about to yield capitulate
fall down bend over or ask for
forgiveness or permission from radical
progressive Democrat socialist in this
state or anywhere else I will fight to
the death and we need solid Republicans
who are willing to fight this day of
wishy-washy Republicans listen we've got
a Republican said they are in this to
win this and it is game on for them if
we roll over if we acquiesce if we only
have speakers that the Democrat Party
approves up what's the point I for one
am proud that I'm bringing a speaker
here who the Democrats don't approve
maybe there's a reason why they don't
prove them it's also interesting that
they won't debate Robert Spencer is the
director of jihad watch and showman
fellow at the David Horowitz Freedom
Center the author of 19 books including
the New York Times bestsellers of the
politically incorrect guide to Islam and
the Crusades and the truth about
Mohammed along with the best-selling
that history of jihad from Mohammed to
Isis forthcoming in 2019 is the
Palestinian delusion the catastrophic
history of the Middle East peace process
mr. Spencer has led seminars on Islam
and jihad for the FBI
the United States Central Command the
United States Army Command and General
Staff College along with the US Army's
asymmetric warfare group and the Joint
Terrorism Task Force as well the Justice
Department's anti-terrorism Advisory
Council and the US intelligence
community he's discussed jihad Islam and
terrorism at a workshop sponsored by the
US State Department and the German
Foreign Ministry ladies and gentlemen it
gives me great pleasure to introduce to
you mr. Robert Spencer thank you very
much for coming thank you for having the
courage to come no seriously I hope the
pardon me I'm going to talk a little bit
about what just happened because it is
emblematic of the crisis that the United
States in general is in today and so I'm
going to be a necessity a little bit
self-referential but please do bear in
mind this is not really about me as
Keith said what has happened to us in
this incident is something that's going
to happen to other people you know we
learned this in fifth grade and
everybody's forgotten you don't give in
to a bully because then the bully will
demand more Oh
and that's exactly what many people in
this area have done not you
you're here that shows that you're not
willing to give in to the bully but to
give in to the bully will only embolden
him and make him more demanding standing
up to the bully and saying you're not
going to give in to what he wants is the
only way to restore some semblance of
order and so in the first place I
commend you for having the courage to be
here and I wanted to point out that we
live in an age of pandemic cowardice in
which everybody has somehow decided that
the best thing to do for a bully is give
him everything he wants
yes and so I'm gonna go through a few
things from this incident to explain
some general principles that I think
it's very important for all of us to
bear in mind as we go forward to do that
I printed out a few of the statements
that were made during the past week in
the first place I'm sure she's a friend
of some of you state senator New
Hampshire state senator Martha s
Penniston wrote very happily this
morning it is clear that Robert Spencer
does not embody the welcoming inclusive
values of Clermont or New Hampshire so
ok I'm on the terrible guy do not embody
the values apparently of this area I
don't know this area very well and I
guess that may be true but I think to
explore a little bit about what she
means by that we need to look at what I
have been doing all these years
and that is I have been trying to call
attention to and raise awareness about
the reality of Islamic Jihad terrorism
and Sharia oppression Sharia is Islamic
law and Islamic law is a recognized body
of laws that cover every aspect of life
without any exception there is nothing
you
even think of doing as a human being
that there are not Sharia laws for and
Sharia mandates the oppression of women
and other people and it has various
other aspects that are in variance with
the principles that we take for granted
and cherish in this Republic and so I've
been trying to call attention to that by
raising awareness about Sharia and try
to catalog in my day-to-day website
jihad watch the jihad activity terrorist
activity that is taking place on an
ongoing basis in the United States and
around the world
now does Martha Hennessy think that
tracking jihad terror activity and
opposing it and opposing Sharia
oppression is not a value that people in
New Hampshire have or should have
actually the answer to that is yes
that's what she thinks she thinks that
to do these things is to be racist and
bigoted and Islamophobic and is thus to
be rejected as not being as inclusive as
she wants to be now what do the people
that she is very concerned not the
attacked have in mind for her let's look
at the Quran the holy book of Islam this
is as many of you know I'm sure somewhat
akin to the Bible in Christianity
although the Quran actually has a
greater status in Islam than the bible
does in christianity because people
understand that the bible is the words
of human beings but inspired by god and
then you have some Bibles you know where
the words of christ are printed in red
and people say this is the direct Word
of God that's great but the Quran is
something diff
all together is in Islamic belief the
Quran was dictated by Allah in every
word of it and he spoke every word of it
now if you compare that to the New
Testament where it says the Gospel
according to Matthew according to Mark
according to Luke and John there is some
recognition and then the letters of Paul
the letters of Peter and so on there's
recognition that there is a human
involvement in this that it is these
human beings who are giving us the Word
of God in Islam there is no according to
its all the words of Allah and so let's
see chapter in the first place let me
say that I got this Quran over in London
in 2009 I was there to film parts of a
documentary spent about a week there was
very interesting place and what of what
I did while I was in London was pretty
much what every American tourist will do
when they go to Britain and that is I
toured the local mosques so in one of
them I went to the Finsbury Park mosque
I was given this Quran the Finsbury Park
mosque is very notorious a few years
back there was an imam which is a Muslim
clergyman a religious leader and he was
the Imam at the Finsbury Park mosque the
mosque of course what's her name Martha
Hennessy would tell you well that's just
like a Muslim Church you know it's very
Muslims go to worship this this man had
two hooks for hands because his hands
had been blown off in a bomb-making
accident you know how that can happen
I'm sure your parish priest to say
explode off bombs but these kinds of
things are common right in any case his
name was Abu Hamza
hello Musti and he was the Imam of the
fence parade Park mosque he was plotting
jihad terror activities a matter of fact
he was involved in setting up an al
Qaeda terrorist group training camp in
Oregon the United States state of Oregon
out west and he was caught he was
removed from his position as the Imam in
this mosque and he is not in prison in
the United States but the thing about
Oklahoma is that of course for years he
was preaching and he was preaching at
the Finsbury Park mosque and he was
preaching hatred of non-muslims
terrorism the need to fight against
unbelievers and so on now a lot of those
people are still around but the Finsbury
Park mosque which still exists assures
us that everything is okay when I went
in there I actually said I hear you had
some trouble here a few years back and
the very nice young man who had met me
there he said yes we did but it's all
God now we're all moderate to you now
and so they gave me this moderate girl
now this moderate Quran is the same text
of course it's an English translation
but it's the same text as any other
Quran but the notes the footnotes that
the explanatory material comes from Syed
abu allah mal Dooney who was a Pakistani
Muslim leader he died in 1979 so that's
not all that long ago so I'll just
remember 1979 and he was the founder of
jamaat-e-islami which was which is still
the largest Muslim political party
Islamic political party that wants to
impose Islamic law in Pakistan and he
wrote also a lengthy commentary on the
Quran it's multi-volume said but this is
a one-volume digest of it now he is very
influential if you go into your local
Islamic bookstore and that's for the
writings of mal de I guarantee you they
will have he is not in other words some
extremist fringe character
pays any attention to and what he says
well first let me give you the verse and
I don't think Martha Hennessy that's her
name right Martha Hennessy I don't think
she's ready she's not here tonight right
I invited her to come I told her up by
her ticket I don't think she took fight
against those who do not believe in
Allah were in the last day even they
though they are the people of the book
the people of the book is the Quran
Stern for primarily for Jews and
Christians and do not hold forbidden
what Allah and his messenger that's
Muhammad the prophet of islam has
forbidden and do not follow the religion
of truth guess which one that is fight
against them until they pay the jizya
which is a tax with willing submission
and feel themselves subdued no that was
the Quran chapter 9 verse 29 but let's
see what mal Doody says that means
because above all I want you to come
away from here
not thinking well Spencer you know he's
a hate-mongering bigoted racist
islamaphobe enemy of everything that is
good and he told us that the wonderful
book of peace the Quran actually said to
fight against unbelievers and O God who
was cherry-picking and taking passages
out of context in ways that completely
are against everything that Muslims
actually believe and so let's we'll deal
with that instead of believing me listen
to my duty I didn't write this book I
didn't write the commentary I am NOT a
Pakistani Muslim leader and none of this
originated with me this is his
explanation of that passage the purpose
for which the Muslims are required to
fight first let's stop there did you get
that required to fight not just you may
fight or if you are attacked you should
fight but you are required to fight and
the purpose is this it's not as one
might think to compel the unbelievers
into embracing Islam so isn't that nice
if they're not fighting they're required
to fight but they're not
to force non-muslims to become Muslims
great okay but let's go on rather its
purpose is to put an end to the
suzerainty that is the rule the
suzerainty the hegemony the political
power of the unbelievers so that the
latter the unbelievers are unable to
rule over people did you get to catch
that the purpose is to put an end to the
suzerainty of the unbelievers so that
the latter are unable to rule over
people the purpose you see is to fight
against unbelievers so that they can
have no political power they are unable
to rule over people not unable to rule
over the Muslim people not unable to
rule over the Palestinians or the Iraqis
or some group of subgroup of the Muslim
people but unable to rule over people
Muslim non-muslim in America in
Australia in France wherever in your
engine the authority to rule should only
be vested in those who follow the true
faith unbelievers who do not follow this
true faith should live in a state of
subordination the Declaration of
Independence says we hold these truths
to be self-evident that all men are
created equal and are endowed by their
creator with certain inalienable rights
and that among these are life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness all men are
created equal those who do not follow
this true faith should live in the state
of subordination and they are endowed by
their creator with certain unalienable
rights
anybody who becomes convinced of the
truth of Islam may accept the faith of
his or her own volition the unbelievers
are required to pay jizya that's that
tax in return for the security provided
to them as
Demi's of an Islamic state Cinzia
symbolizes the submission of the
unbelievers to the suzerainty of Islam
now I don't want this to get too
complicated I want to be very clear I
used another word there I was quoting
mal duty and he said that the
unbelievers have to live as dim Me's
what does that mean
the protected people that sounds nice
doesn't it to be protected like here we
are maybe in an Islamic state the
Muslims be outside guarding in case
anybody wanted to attack the place
Martha Hennessy came by with it with an
aka so the protection however that is
envisioned is not exactly like that this
is another Islamic book this is reliance
of the traveler which is a manual of
Islamic law you want to know what
Islamic law is it's in here don't
believe me let's go to the al-azhar
Islamic Research Academy al-azhar is
actually the foremost Islamic
institution among Sunni Muslims and
that's 85 percent of Muslims worldwide
the Symons Barack Obama when he was
giving his outreach speech to the
Islamic world in June 2009 he chose a
lots are to speak because it is such a
prestigious and ancient and venerable
and respected institution and now Lazar
has a little note at the beginning of
this book and it says that this book
conforms to the practice and faith of
the Orthodox Sunni community it conforms
to the practice and faith of the
Orthodox living community so if you want
to know what Sunni Islam is all about
this is it certified by one of their
foremost authorities and it says that
Muslims must make war upon Jews
Christians and Zara lesbians until they
Muslim or else pay the non-muslim poll
tax you just heard me quote that from
the Quran and say the same thing from
mout duty and if they are conquered and
they're living as protected people the
dim knees in the Islamic state this is
what that means that you've got to pay
this tax that tax the jizya that's what
the word means tax the Muslims don't
have to pay the non-muslims actually are
responsible for the upkeep of the
Muslims the Calif umar the second
successor of muhammad as the leader of
the muslims and a revered figure in
sunni islam he said be sure to always
collect the jizya because it is the
source of your livelihood in other words
the non-muslims are going to pay for you
to live you don't have to become a
farmer or shopkeeper or a merchant or
whatever because you meet what you need
to do is conquer the unbelievers make
them submit as the Damis and then they
will pay you also the novel some
subjects are required obliged that says
rather to comply with Islamic rules and
the Islamic rules that they have to
comply with are they are distinguished
from Muslims in dress wearing a white
cloth belt or zunar now that might seem
irrelevant they are distinguished from
Muslims in dress but what that is is
it's so that you always know if you're a
Muslim that a non-muslim is coming
because the next rule is non-muslims are
not greeted with assalamu alaykum
assalamu alaykum ancien angeles live
reading it means peace be upon you
when a Muslim meets another Muslim if
they are devout and observant then are
we having trouble with the video
because you see you strike me down
thousands of people and I wasn't even
gonna ask that it be video before all
this happened so anyway the thing is
assalamu alaikum peace be upon you all
muslim i see you your muscle muslim and
exactly peace be upon you but if you see
a normal son coming then you do not say
peace be upon you you say peace be upon
those who are rightly guided
that is peace be upon us because there's
more to it than that also the
non-muslims must keep to the side of the
street
now you may I just found out you're from
Alabama I heard overheard before your
time before any of our times there were
the Jim Crow laws in Alabama and there
were Jim Crow laws all over the south
and the black people one of the things
they would have to do was step off the
sidewalk if a white person was coming in
as a sign of superiority and inferiority
was a sign of deference of submission
certain kind of submission my experience
that well there you go and this was a
terrible that this is a block in the
history of the United States and it's a
great thing that the United States is
the only country really where there was
an ingrained racism that has been
overcome although now they're the
leftist to do their best to bring it
back but the Jim Crow laws actually they
got nothing on this just like it wasn't
Hitler who invented the badge the
distinguishing dress for the Jews it was
the Muslims he stipulated these cloths
have not changed over 1400 years
stipulated that the non-muslims had to
wear a separate kind of clothing they
are not to be greeted with the with the
peace they have to step off the street
of a Muslim is coming and defer and I've
known many people from Lebanon Syria
which are supposedly moderate places
they say that's still happens because
the Muslims demanded and you could get
beat up or worse if you just if you just
walked along the street like anybody
else they may not build higher than or
as high as the Muslims buildings that is
you're always in a state of submission
and they are forbidden to openly display
wine or pork to ring church bells or
display crosses you have to do it all
furtively and privately Eastern Eastern
Churches churches in the Islamic world
even to this day they don't have bells
because of these rules they have to be
very quiet and furtive about their
worship in Egypt the Coptic churches
many times nowadays and Muslims build
big mosques right next to the churches
and then broadcast the Islamic call to
prayer over loudspeakers into the church
while the church is having the services
they are forbidden to build new churches
or to repair old ones so that the
communities are always in decline and
the Muslim communities are always broke
and in Egypt also this is playing out
today even though these laws are not
fully enforced in Egypt today they were
abolished there in the 1850s but because
these are Islamic laws because these are
parts of Sharia which is considered to
be given by God as much as Christians
believe the Ten Commandments come from
God
there are many Muslims in Egypt and all
over the Islamic world who think we've
got to reapply these levels and that
means that the Christians are not
allowed to build new churches Egypt is
has a lot of Christians the official
number is about 6% but some people
estimate it's as many as 20% and they
don't have enough churches but if they
try to repair one of their old churches
or to build a new one the government
says you can't have a permit for that if
you come in and say I want a permit to
build a mosque you'll get the permit
right away but a church can't get a
permit a lot of times the they get the
permit and then they start building and
then a mob forms and knocks down what
they do because it's against Islamic law
so this is
just the opposite of being endowed by
the creator with certain unalienable
rights this is just the opposite of all
men are created equal
Islam actually institutionalizes
discrimination and contempt for the
non-muslim so what exactly are the
welcoming inclusive values of Clermont
or New Hampshire that Martha Hennessy
wants to reinforce she's been told I'm
sure she doesn't know me from Adam but
she's been told that I am indeed an
enemy of all that is good and stand
against all her values the problem is
with that that she is naively an
ignorant women and it was shut down a
few years back because it was discovered
to have been funneling its charitable
contributions to the terror group Hamas
and Hamas was obviously using it for
malevolent purposes when the Holy Land
Foundation went on trial when it first
happened it was raided its offices were
raided by the FBI now the FBI is a whole
other story but back then it was a
fairly worthwhile organization and the
FBI went into their offices and carted
out all these documents one of the
documents they found in the Holy Land
Foundation offices was a program for
North America from a group called the
Muslim Brotherhood Muslim Brotherhood is
the one of the largest Islamic
organizations in the world al-qaeda and
Isis the terror groups come from it and
the Muslim Brotherhood took power in
Egypt a few years back but they were
kicked and so Mis ruled the country that
they were kicked out after a year but
there's still very much a presence in
Egypt and they have a presence all over
the world every without exception every
major Muslim organization in the United
States is connected to the Muslim
Brotherhood and we know that in large
part because they were listed in this
document also listed in this document
was the objective of the Muslim
Brotherhood in the United States which
it said was and I quote eliminating or
destroying Western
from within and sabotaging it's
miserable house by their hands and the
hands of the believers so that it falls
and the laws religion is victorious over
other religions now let me say that
again eliminating and destroying Western
civilization from within and sabotaging
it's miserable house by their hands and
the hands of the believers so that it
falls and the laws religion is
victorious over other religions there's
one part of that I want to emphasize by
their hands and the hands of the
believers who's that their hands that's
us we and Western civilization they're
going to make us destroy ourselves how
have they done that one of the primary
ways that Islamic organizations and
their allies on the Left have done that
in the United States is to make people
think that it's racist and bigoted and
hateful to oppose a radically violent
and expansionist ideology that would
subjugate large portions of the
population and deny them basic rights
[Laughter]
over that portion of the evening the now
think about that they're gonna make us
eliminate and destroy Western
civilization by our own hand what better
way but to stigmatize any resistance to
their program and look how well it's
worked
Martha Hennessy not only got this thing
canceled from the second one the Elks
but she thinks she's righteous in doing
so now you could say as Martha were here
she would probably say well I'm against
terrorism of course and I'm gonna fight
terrorism but you're just a bigot who
goes too far well let me tell you
something else the Muslim Brotherhood
organizations in the United States the
Council on american-islamic relations
the Muslim Public Affairs Council the
Muslim American Society these
Society of North America every other one
that I could name everybody without
exception every last person who calls
attention to this threat gets the same
treatment I got this week it ain't just
me not only that but there is not a
single person that those groups the
Council on american-islamic relations is
the foremost and others there is not a
single one that says these guys over
here
they're counter-terrorist analysts who
are okay
there aren't any it's all a scam you see
they portray anybody who sticks his neck
out about this as a racist bigoted
hateful person now why do they do that
because you see look what I just did
tonight
I read their books that's the worst
thing I could possibly do because one on
earth can they say that ain't in our
books it is it's obvious I cut you can
look in the books and see if I made it
up it's all in here and you can go get
these books on Amazon or anywhere else
and you'll see that it's all in there
and worse and what else can they say
well we don't really pay attention to
those things you're reading from Fringe
guys now duty as I explained before is
not fringe and if I actually doubt you'd
have an Islamic bookstore around here
but if you do you will soon and when you
do go in and ask for mount duty and they
will give you ten books of his they
carry or more and this is not friend to
tell us are where did Barack Obama speak
Alice her last heart says you got to
make more against the Jews and
Christians and subjugate them under the
rule of Islamic law and denied them all
those rights it's right in here where I
read so did Obama go to speak before a
fringe extremist organization or maybe
these things are a little more
mainstream than Martha and
he wants to acknowledge now there's more
kevin Landrigan are you here
Kevin Landrigan of the Union Leader no
oddly enough yeah oddly enough you know
you I I've got it I've got to say I'm
sorry I have to apologize because I
thought these people were journalists
but journalists actually check their
sources and get both sides of the story
and last week kevin Landrigan of the New
Hampshire union-leader
wrote an article about my coming here
and that was the first I had heard that
he knew anything about it
he never contacted me he never asked me
for comment not before or after I wrote
him tonight and invited him to be here
I'm surprised he didn't make it
and I would have sprung for his ticket
to Martha's and Kevin's on the house but
they didn't come now in this article in
the New Hampshire union-leader it says
that I am it quotes actually the
Southern Poverty Law Center and it says
I am one of the most prolific thank you
one of the most prolific anti-muslim
figures in the United States now in the
first place the Southern Poverty Law
Center there is a paper in Washington
the Washington Post and it has been
widely criticized by President Trump and
many other people for being not really a
newspaper but the propaganda organ for
the left and the Washington Post ran a
big story last year saying the Southern
Poverty Law Center is labeling people as
hate groups unfairly I'm about five hate
groups for the Southern Poverty Law
me individually my website jihad watch
the David Horowitz Freedom Center that
I'm affiliated with the American freedom
Defense Initiative that I'm vice
president of what else I'm a couple
other groups too in there but I mean I'm
a really bad guy but the thing is is
that what the southern even the
Washington Post admitted that the
Southern Poverty Law Center does this
what they're trying to do is discredit
people like me and by no means only mean
by saying that we are like the Klan the
Ku Klux Klan we are like David Duke we
are like the neo-nazis and so nobody
who's decent should have anything to do
with us now you know that do they say
Spencer says this and it's false no they
don't say that do they say Spencer says
that all Muslims do this or that well
they do say that I'm an anti-muslim
figure but I've never actually said
anything about also if you can't
generalize about people that way and
though I'm constantly accused of doing
so I challenge any of these people to
find in nineteen books and thousands of
articles anytime rather than any place
where I've actually done that there's a
spectrum among Muslims of belief
knowledge and fervor just as there is
among Christians some of you may be very
serious Christians and some of you may
not be and all of you probably know some
people who are very serious Christians
and also some people who say they're
Christians but are not very serious
Christians and it's the same thing in
Islam so what I deal with is Islamic
teaching some Muslims take it very
seriously some don't some know all about
it
some don't it's just like anything else
but anyway in dealing with this Islamic
teaching Kevin Landrigan quotes the SPLC
the southern probably in Law Center
saying oh I'm auntie muscle so let me
ask you this in World War two we fought
the Nazis the Nazis you see those films
they have this huge crowd and Hitler's
going through and they are cheering
wildly they love it
right and yet when we fought the Nazis
did people say we were anti German
bigots who just hate Germans now there
were some Germans a small group that
didn't like Hitler and didn't like the
Nazis after World War two of course
every German became a part of that group
and they all said oh yes yes we hate it
if you had nothing to do it in the only
went along because he'd kill us but the
fact is that if I am a Muslim then to
fight against the Nazis was anti German
and we shouldn't have done it because
that would be bigotry Reina is the
Democratic Party Chairman is that the
Democratic Party chairman of the whole
state or the Arabs is very ok Democratic
Party Chairman of New Hampshire ok and
he said the new adventure Republican
Party is bringing an anti-muslim white
supremacist Robert Spencer well I
thought when I saw this Keith actually
showed this part to me and I I couldn't
believe it I thought what a dope because
see there's this guy Richard Spencer and
he is really more of a media creation
than anything else but he's a real Nazi
I've had a little bit of interaction
with him on Twitter and he said I know
you want to chew you'll you have changed
your name well your name is not really
Spencer what is your real name
chew and I mean this guy is really
seriously anti-semitic and a Nazi but
his name is Richard be Spencer and my
name is Robert be Spencer and somehow
there's a large number of people when
they see these two names they can't get
tell them apart ask Raymond Buckley
about former president Robert Nixon
atheist philosopher Robert Dawkins
because Raymond Buckley called me a
white supremacist I challenged Raymond I
couldn't find an email address but I
found him on Twitter and I wrote to him
I'll think enough he didn't answer and
he I asked and find something and
everything I've written I've written so
much stuff find something that's racist
find something that's white supremacist
you won't be able to because there ain't
anything in there like that this is not
a racial issue there are Muslims of all
races there are Islamic Jihad ease of
all races to say that to oppose Jihad
terror is racist is just it's ridiculous
and incoherent it would be like saying
that opposing Hitler was racist or
eighty Germany it had nothing to do with
it I mean Hitler was the racist not the
people that were fighting against it and
the people who are who I am trying to
raise awareness about are the ones who
are the real bigots and the really
intolerant people and the people who
will really carry out oppression if they
come into power me I like the US
Constitution I want to see the freedom
of speech the freedom of religion all
these things but I don't want to see one
group gaining hegemony over the others
and subjugating the others as inferiors
under their law so I'm a terrible guy
John P Greg of the illustrious Valley
News is Johnny here I invited him I
don't understand it
they could have come and seen for
themselves I thought they were
journalists you see what I mean they
said this guy this guy is a terrible guy
and he's gonna do terrible things and
they could have come and had a story you
know The Gargoyle spoke and and he said
let us hate everyone and be
and here we had the story and the
Democrats were right and Reagan and
Buckley was right and Martha Hennessy
was right they're not here they don't
care maybe they know that I'm not
anything like that in real life but John
P Gregg I can think of a few things that
stands for word but I would say is has
the goal of vilifying and maligning
Muslims and the Islamic faith that's
actually another quote from the Southern
Poverty Law Center but you notice he
doesn't quote me he didn't he didn't
reach out to me when he wrote his first
story I wrote to him after that and then
he asked me for comment on the second
story that's another thing he never
bothered to try to contact me for his
first story and don't think I was
thinking anything I've seen about his
middle name just something like
Pumpkinhead but anyway the thing is that
the gold of vilifying and maligning
Muslims what did I do tonight I read
from the Quran I read from in respected
commentary on the Quran I read from a
manual of Islamic law that is certified
by one of the foremost authorities in
Sunni Islam as reflecting the practice
and faith of the Orthodox Sunni
community how is that vilifying if I
came in here and I said hello I am
Robert Spencer not Richard and you said
he said hello I am Robert Spencer not
Richard what'd I say your vilifying me
all I did was quote you right I just
quoted their stuff but it seems like
they maybe there's some people who don't
want these things to be known and that's
the real problem
so notice also that the Sullivan County
Republican Committee and I know some of
you are part of that or two
so I know this isn't you
but Sullivan County Republican Committee
moved a fundraiser featuring a speaker
with controversial views on Islam that
is equitable and the owners of the
initial venue the Eastman Community
Association were worried about possible
protests in the interest of Public
Safety we have no choice but to cancel
Friday's event they didn't have a choice
they had to in the interest of Public
Safety now what did I say at the
beginning you give in to a bully you're
gonna get more bullies so if you if the
Sullivan County Republican Committee or
if Eastman Community Association Thanks
well they'll cancel Spencer and this
problem will go away who was gonna put
on the possible protests was I going to
come out and incite you all and say
let's go in and protesting the mosque of
course not
yes sir cars and setting trash cans on
the fire when the Eastman Community
Association actually hosted a
transgendered speaker talking about
transgenderism that nothing happened
right
when they have the guys spouting carbon
dioxide will be hating about a man-made
climate change so obviously it was the
left that was going to be protesting and
the Eastman Community Association said
they had no choice but to submit and
capped out so you know what the left is
gonna do they're gonna say if the
Eastern Community Association ever does
anything else we don't like we'll just
do that again because we already know
they'll fold
now John Gregg wrote a follow-up article
this morning because he's such an
intrepid journalist and he said Ozma L
honey the lead organizer of the United
Valley interfaith project pointed out
that the right-wing Norwegian extremists
onder's Behring Breivik who killed 77
people in a 2011 bomb attack and
shooting spree appeared to be influenced
by Spencer Trebek quoted Spencer 64
times in his manifesto yes he did quote
me you know who else he quoted Barack
Obama John F Kennedy Charles Darwin we
better lock these guys up this is
terrible
orbán their books the fact is Anders
Behring Breivik had this thousand page
manifesto it was just a lot of crazy
nutty stuff and one of the things that
he did was he took the script now this
is also an interesting little tidbit I
was in a documentary in like 2002 Islam
what the West needs to know I think it's
on YouTube but they might have taken it
off by now but it's Lomb what the West
needs to know was a documentary as I
said featuring many people speaking
including me about various aspects of
Islamic teaching and once again we
quoted the Koran we quoted Islamic
authorities there was nothing insightful
iein see ite inciting about it it was
very insightful si tht passionately and
there was nothing calling for violence
or justifying violence or anything of
the kind
it was just a documentary about Islamic
teaching trying to explicate what had
happened oh you got it yeah there it is
still there what did that explicate what
had happened on
eleven brevet now the there was a
transcript of this documentary in
brevets manifesto and if you've ever
seen a movie script or a play script you
know how it is whoever speaks they name
who speaks and then there's what he's
supposed to say Hamlet to be or not to
be that is the question
and every time Hamlet speaks it says
again Hamlet right so every time I spoke
in that thing it said Robert Spencer and
it's a hundred pages long or whatever
the transcript now the interesting
tidbit is the transcript was never
published anywhere how did previck get
it still don't know but I don't have the
answer to that I just offer that to you
for consultation but he had it anyway
and it was flawless even though he was
not a native English speaker and it
makes me yes I get quoted every time I
speak and that's the majority of the
quotes there in there but there's
another more even more important thing
Braddock says in his manifesto that he
was influenced not by me but by al-qaeda
the jihad terrorist group and he said he
saw in the 90s before 9/11 and also
incidentally before I had published
anything about Islam I was doing
consulting about Islam in the 90s but I
had not published any books and I did
not have the website he says that he was
influenced by al-qaeda to become violent
not only that but he named me and
several other people and he says what's
wrong with these people as they don't
call for violence
so he's saying I did not influence him
they say oh yes but see he's against
Islamization and you're against
Islamization okay if every idea is
discredited by somebody being violent
then the Democrats
not be socialists and yet they are even
though millions of people have been
killed in the name of socialism so that
can't be it the whole thing is a wash I
I did not influence Brevik it's just
used as a part of my rap sheet to turn
people away from what I might say he
paints Muslims with one brush says Ozma
help Unni of United Valley interfaith
project did I paint Muslims with one
brush let me ask you did I say all
Muslims believe this no did I not say
exactly the opposite yes if you go to 20
of my talks on YouTube and watch every
last one of them I will say that in
every one of them or most of them and I
will never say that all Muslims believe
this but the idea that I paint Muslims
with one brush this is here again this
is just a false statement designed to
make people think there's something
wrong with this we shouldn't have and
then she goes on to say there's no one
Sharia for the Islamic world my Sharia
teaches me that I should make sure my
neighbor's don't go hungry my Sharia
teaches me to take care of the poor and
orphan oh okay well I'm glad she has
such a lovely Sharia but let's think
about this carefully Sharia Islamic law
is the law of the land in several
countries in the world the governments
of several countries in the world are
dedicated to apply Sharia in every
sphere of life that they can and these
countries are the Islamic Republic of
Iran the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
Pakistan for the most part northern
Sudan parts of Somalia do you start to
see a pattern
every last one of those countries every
place where Sharia is applied it denies
basic rights to women to nice basic
rights to non-muslims denies the freedom
of speech everywhere Sharia is applied
in the akshay province in Indonesia as
well way away from the Middle East
everywhere it's applied it looks the
same so yeah I know there's not one Sri
I've never said that was once Sharia
there are several schools of islamic
jurisprudence Shafi'i Maliki humbly and
Hanafi for the Sunnis and they're the
Jafari school for the Shiites these are
schools of thought that apply that have
different understandings of Sharia but
I'll tell you they agree on 75% of
everything and Ozma L Unni if she has
studied this she knows this to be truth
but was intentionally saying the
opposite now I'm not saying maybe she
doesn't but you can look out at the
Sharia states in the world and see what
Sharia is any heart you can also look at
Islamic history this is a book I wrote
last year the history of jihad from
Mohammed to Isis 1,400 years of jihad
activity and I wrote it I did not write
in it what I thought what I did was I
went and read the Islamic historians a
lot of the great Islamic rulers of the
past just like a non-muslim rulers they
had what are known as court historians a
court historian is the guy who writes
down what happens and so he's right
there when it happens and then he goes
to his office and writes it down and
then as he does this every day you have
a history of the reign of so-and-so and
a lot of these court historians their
writings are readily available and I
read them and I read wherever I could
primary sources about the Islamic
conquests and for 1,400 years every
where Muslims went they created conflict
with the non-muslims and attempted to
subjugate them under the rule of Islamic
law and nary are one of them said
wait my Sharia is caring for the poor
and hungry
my Sharia is blowing milk bottles
through a straw nobody did this nope
that was never any large scale
resistance to the violent jihad ease
among peaceful Muslims and there was
never any time when the non-muslims and
the Muslims lived in peace except when
the Muslims had the hegemony and the
non-muslims were paying the taxes so all
this is terrible what is it now it's not
welcoming or inclusive well I would
submit to you that what is not welcoming
or inclusive are the Islamic jihadists
who believe this and there are some in
the United States there are some in
other countries they do have a program
to bring their rule to America and we
need to be aware of it that's all that's
all I've been doing and so if that is so
terrible and I am completely silenced
and other people like me are completely
silenced what will be the result the
result will be that they will be able to
do whatever they want and everybody will
be afraid to speak out against them
because they'll be afraid of being
called a racist and a bigot and an
Islamophobe and not being welcoming or
inclusive and clubs will close down
their events and say that they are
beyond the pale of acceptable discourse
and no decent people should be seen in
their company and then what will happen
lead jihad will advance unimpeded
unopposed and eventually win and so what
we have to do my friends and I'm known
preaching to the choir for this part but
the video is going there we have to
stand up to them and say we're not going
to be intimidated and we're not going to
be bullied and refused to allow them to
manipulate us and so what I think is
probably one of the most distasteful
elements of this whole episode is the
fact that there are people in the
Sullivan County Republican Party who say
well really can't we just get another
speaker it's not about me
you give in to them on this you're just
going to
give it they're just gonna make you give
in to them on everything else and so
what's the point of having an opposition
you're not in opposition anymore you're
just more of the same just like Mitt
Romney and Paul Ryan and all those guys
are not really an opposition party to
the Democrats they're just more of the
same and the only real opposition is
that represented by the president so
that is where I will end up these are
difficult times and they call for
courage and they're gonna probably get
worse before they get better
but we do have one tremendous weapon on
our side and that is the truth ausma ll
Cooney said something else I forgot to
mention she said I don't know any Muslim
who doesn't know Robert Spencer
isn't she painting Muslims with a broad
brush I don't know any Muslim who
doesn't know Robert Spencer thanks mom
thanks this man is extremely dangerous
this man is extremely dangerous I had to
laugh but what she fears is not me
what she fears is the truth what she
fears is Americans knowing what's in the
Koran and Americans knowing what's in
Islamic law and Americans knowing what's
in Islamic history that's what she's
afraid of
because the more Americans who know the
less likely they are to be able to make
us eliminate and destroy Western
civilization by our own hands and I know
none of you my friends here tonight are
going to allow that to happen so thank
you very much
if you have any questions yes sir well
it's your right if you really believe
that you cannot compromise or change
these people then what do you do yes yes
sure no problem
I have no secrets I want people to know
what I say because if they really saw
what I say then they would say wait a
minute this guy isn't really all that
dangerous or evil now I forgot what
saying being some evil we know that
we're not gonna change them yeah because
it's it's a religion religions tend to
be resistant to change you can't just
say hey would you knock that stuff about
fighting the unbelievers out of the
Quran please just redline that they're
not gonna do that you know and the Quran
says I quoted you this before in chapter
5 verse 3 this day I have perfected your
religion for you Allah speaking of
course if your religion is perfect then
it admits of no reform you're not going
to change it and anybody who tries to
change it is going to be vilified
innovation b-dah is a great sin in Islam
because you know you don't innovate when
the religion is already perfect so what
do you do what we need to do is enforce
our own laws and then these things will
fall into place the solution is actually
quite simple that we say we believe in
the freedom of speech here and so we do
not take kindly to bringing in a system
of laws that denies the freedom of
speech and we believe in the Equality of
rights of all people before the law and
so you will be prosecuted if you try to
spread this I
geology that denies the Equality of
rights of all people before the law and
on and on and on for example very very
easy example polygamy polygamy having
more than one life and in the quran
chapter four verse three your man is
allowed to have four wives up to four
wives as well as the captives of the
right hand which are slave girls there's
no limit on those so as many as you can
capture four wives now in America
polygamy is illegal because it is
considered to be a denial of the human
dignity of women because they're reduced
to you don't have marriage as a union of
two people but you have the their
commodities who they don't have the same
rights in the same dignity as the male's
do all right so it's illegal it's
illegal in the United States a few years
back there was a fire in an apartment
building in the Bronx in New York City
and the fire killed several people it
was a terrible tragedy and I was reading
the story about the fire the next day in
the New York Times and it said that the
man who lived there was killed along
with at least two of his wives and that
he was living in a polygamous
arrangement he was a Muslim migrant from
I believe North Africa and there are
many other stories as a matter of fact
Ibrahim Hooper of the Council on
american-islamic relations has admitted
says there there are actually thousands
of polygamous families in the United
States one of them was a guy named Suraj
Gibbon will Hajj who last year went out
to New Mexico
he was living in Florida I believe and
in New Mexico he left one of his wives
in Florida went out to New Mexico with
another one of his wives and started a
terror training camp where they were
actually training children to be school
shooters you know go into the schools
with guns one of the
it's one of the students but they were
they were caught they were stopped for
which we can all be grateful but see
Rajeev and maja was in a polygamous
arrangement he had more than one wife
now the United States is obviously not
enforcing the laws against polygamy
against Muslims today because it would
be Islamophobic it would be racist and
there would be a big snafu and so
they're not it's not being enforced but
I suggest to you that if they had been
enforced then this terrorist suraj
Amandla Hajj would have been stopped
before he started his terror training
camp in New Mexico he never would have
gotten the opportunity to do that
another thing is female genital
mutilation which is done to control
women and Mohammed said to do it people
constant every last story on this in the
media says this has nothing to do with
Islam it's a cultural practice but I can
show you in here where Mohammed says
it's an honor for men and for women
and most of the schools of us some of
the schools of islamic law require it
some of them say it's a very good thing
to do even if it's not required and so
that's the kind of thing they differ on
there were a couple of doctors last year
who were arrested in Detroit for doing
it and they were put on trial the first
ever trial is of FGM in the United
States and then a judge dropped the
charges and said you can't have a law
against FGM in the United States it's
their freedom of religion well we're
gonna have to decide the LDS Church the
Latter day Saints Church had polygamy
and the United States government said in
1890 that the state of Utah the
territory of Utah could not be admitted
to the United States as a state until
the LDS Church outlawed polygamy
now nobody cried about religious freedom
we understood them that there was a
limit religious freedom obviously is not
something that we means we have to sit
idly by and allow ourselves to be
and subjugated because it's their
religion it was never understood to be a
suicide pill for the entire Republic and
the the the polygamy was outlawed for
the LDS Church because it was considered
to be against the national interest and
against existing American laws and it's
the same thing if we can't enforce laws
against female genital mutilation women
will suffer and also we are allowing
Sharia into the United States which will
only lead to more Sharia which will lead
inevitably to their laws about
conquering and subjugating unbelievers
so what we need to do is be true to
ourselves enforce our own laws and we
will go a great way to rolling this back
yes sir
yeah it was the manuscript of a piece of
the Quran and it was carbon dated to 575
AD now the problem with that is that
Muhammad became a prophet he was visited
by the angel Gabriel he said and
according to the Islamic traditions this
he became a prophet in the year 610 and
the revelations that Gabriel gave to him
according to Islamic tradition are
collected in the Quran so the Quran
according to Islamic tradition was
collected between the years 610 I mean
was given between the year 610 and 632
when Muhammad died and then collected
together into this form by the Caliph
Othman the third successor of muhammad
in the year 653 now that's the story
this exploded that story because you see
if there's a piece of the Quran from 575
and then Muhammad didn't start getting
it in 610 now I could have told him that
already nine years ago I wrote a book
which is available now
although I don't have any with me of
that one but it's called did Muhammad
exist and I look into the earliest
Islamic records about Muhammad and other
relevant material and show that there is
no mention of Muhammad or Islam for the
first 60 years after Islam was supposed
to have started there's there's a
straight mention of Muhammad here in one
thing from 648 years after he's supposed
to have died but it only just mentions
it by name doesn't give anything of all
the things we know about his biography
that come later and it seems more likely
that the Quran was actually put together
by a group of people using existing
Jewish and Christian material and some
Sorrell a stream material and making a
new religion out of it because in those
days this is a very short story out of a
very long one so I apologize if this is
kind of confusing but in those days
there were no constitutions or
Parliament's or that kind of thing codes
of law there was just the king and the
king generally had essentially absolute
power and the empires when there were
empires were held together by religion
generally in the days in the days that
Muhammad is supposed to have lived there
were two great empires two great
superpowers in the world the Byzantine
Empire which was Christian the Eastern
Roman Empire and the Persian Empire
which was Zoroastrian and those
religions were what everybody was a
Roman or Byzantine because they were
Christian that was what was the glue of
the Empire so the Arabs conquered all
this territory very quickly in the 7th
century and they did not mention that
they had a new religion when they did it
only later do we start hearing about
their new religion and so I posited in
that book did Muhammad exist that they
made up the religion in order to glue
their empire together and keep it strong
after they had made the conquests and
that Islam actually arises a little bit
later than the traditional Islamic
sources say and Mohammed is a mythologic
figure and the Quran is made up of all
this old stuff that was put together by
editors and that's why you have a piece
of paradise
yes well I think that contrary to be
inclusive unfortunately we need to speak
about the differences rather than the
similarities now that goes against all
the conventional wisdom and that's where
people are gonna say oh see Spencer you
really are a hate monger because all the
Interfaith dialog initiatives whether
they are carried out by the Catholics or
Protestants any Christian Muslim dialog
they always focus on what the two have
in common and I think well that's just
great but then why are we all one big
happy family what we need to do is
discuss what divides us and then we
might possibly come to some new
understanding but we'll never do that by
talking about how well both in the Bible
and in the Quran there's Adam and Eve
and God creates them and they get
expelled from the garden it's all yeah
okay well then why are you have a
separate religion so there is one very
key passage from for for this particular
question which is chapter 91 verse 7
which says that Allah created the soul
and perfectly proportioned it and imbued
it with evil and with piety he imbued it
with evil and with piety
now once again I'm not asking you to
believe me mal Duty says that this means
the Creator has embedded in man's nature
tendencies and inclinations towards both
good and evil
now that's fundamentally different from
the Christian understanding the
Christian understanding is that God is
good and created human beings good and
it was their rejection of God that
brought evil into the world and so you
return to God and he will be good with
the Quran the good and evil are both
they're both from Allah and I think that
that's a
telling difference in the two stories
because if you think that Allah put both
good and evil within you then you're not
really gonna have a problem when a law
says when you meet the unbelievers
strike the necks or fight against the
people of the book until they pay the
jizya with willing submission and feel
themselves subdued you will have no
trouble thinking that Allah might
command you to do things that other
people would think are evil that's what
he does yes to the point of where is
America and where are we going I believe
it was 1954 when Abdul Nasser was giving
a public speech and one of the questions
was the Muslims were trying to take over
Egypt remember anything do you think my
wife is gonna go around with a cheetah
yeah you try to tell them you you
convinced them to put it off yeah what
we're talking about is Gamal Abdel
Nasser who was the president of Egypt in
the 50s and there's a very famous video
which is problems certainly still on
YouTube where he is criticizing the
Wilson Brotherhood because the Egyptian
government has been fighting against the
Muslim Brotherhood ever since the Muslim
Brotherhood was founded in 1928 the
Egypt is not a state that in that
imposes Islamic law although as I
explained before it has a very strong
influence there but the Islamic state I
mean I'm sorry the the the Egyptian
state wants to prevent the Brotherhood
from establishing an Islamic state in
Egypt so the Muslim Brotherhood was
saying all the women should cover their
heads because it's in Islamic law that
women
cover their heads and never venture out
in public with head uncovered in those
days you can find pictures of Egypt
pictures of people walking along the
street in Egypt in 1958 or 68 or
graduation photos of colleges in Egypt
and the women are all there and they're
not wearing their head coats and now
take the same University the same
college the same street all the women
wearing head coverings and Nasser
actually scoffs at this and says you
he's saying speaking to the Brotherhood
guys saying you want all the women to
cover their heads you convinced them and
everybody last but the laughter
ultimately caught his throat I mean he
actually ended up this all happened
after he died but the Brotherhood did
make tremendous inroads and was able to
make most women think in Egypt that they
had to cover their heads and if they
don't they do get attacked on the street
and that's happened to American
reporters in Egypt female reporters who
go there and they're not covered know
what how did they do that
they appealed to Islam they said this is
Islam if you don't cover your head Allah
will hang you by your hair upside down
in hell for all eternity
and so on and so they were able to
appeal to people on that basis and
transform Egyptian society now you might
ask well how the Egyptian society
they were always Muslim how did or at
least they have been since the seventh
century
how did there come yeah well they were
Arabs before they were Muslims but no
actually I'm sorry they were not Arabs
before they were Muslims they were there
before they were Muslims but the Arabs
came with Islam the cops were were and
are not Arabs the original in
of Egypt and but more recently I would
love to go into all this history but
people find it in big history but most
recently what happened was under Western
pressure Egypt abolished the dimi status
and the second-class status for
non-muslims in the 1850s so did the
Ottoman Empire the the Turks at that
time and because it there was a
widespread perception that Islam that
the Islamic empires had failed the
Ottoman Empire was the last great
Islamic empire and it fell in 1900 war 1
and was completely abolished by 1923
when the Caliphate was abolished the
Caliphate being the successors the
successors of Mohammed there was a
widespread understanding in those days
that Islam had failed because this great
Islamic empire the ottoman empire that
looked like it was gonna conquer europe
did not conquer europe and ultimately
fell apart and who was in the ascendancy
the British Christians and the French
Christians and the Americans Christians
and so Ataturk the founder of modern
Turkey actually was he hated Islam and
he set up turkey on secular lines
modeling it after Western governments
Egypt to a lesser degree also adopted
Western secular ways of government and
ever since then there's been this
tension in Egypt and elsewhere between
those who think this is all done
legitimate and we have to restore
Islamic law and those who are opposed to
Islamic law yes
each of attempting to maintain yes he is
about reforming yes he did he gave a
speech to a bunch of Imams saying they
needed to work for Islamic reform
nothing happened
nothing was done because you don't mess
with the perfect really didn't we see
and see see however that he did
overthrow the Brotherhood in Egypt in
2013 and see this is where it becomes
difficult and paradoxical because in the
United States we believe in democracy we
have democracy here at least for now
maybe not for much longer things keep
going the way they're going but in Egypt
if you have a popular vote the Muslim
Brotherhood will win because most of the
people there are Muslims and most of
them think a Muslim majority state
should be governed by Islamic law and so
CC has a very uphill battle he has of
great difficulty and unfortunately he
has to practice steam control you know
steam control you have a steam boiler
but you if it gets too hot you have to
let off some steam which is where that
expression comes from so that it doesn't
explode you have to be anyway the Sisi
government practices steam control which
means they let the Brotherhood do what
they want to some degree so that they
let off some steam and they don't try to
overthrow the government and one of the
things that he lets them do far too
often is persecute the Christians in
Egypt who had a terrible time
yes and pushing down yes
so they good the name J Smith the guy
PhD devotes his life to the subject has
devoted much of his life apparently
Annie's American assistant he seems to
be working with a group in Europe
nationwide worldwide that is researching
the history and semen and may in some of
his videos be reflecting that there may
be a conclusion at some point with
plenty of evidence that the Koran was
fabricated as opposed to oh yeah being a
religion well I went into that earlier
yeah it was put together I do believe
that it's in my book did Muhammad exist
there was a lot of material about the
Quran and how it doesn't look like it
was written by one person which of
course say Islamic belief it was all all
not written by Muhammad but it was all
recited by Muhammad and written down and
that well a lot of the contradictions in
it come from the fact that it was
combined from various different
traditions we could talk about that all
night but anyway it's in the book did
Muhammad exist yes sir
in World War two yeah well as a matter
of fact what I do is write books folks
so pardon all commercials but yes who
wants revenge for what oh yeah sure
absolutely
but I have a book coming out on December
3rd that you can pre-order now at Amazon
the Palestinian delusion the
catastrophic history of the Middle East
peace process and it really is it's
another history book it shows all the
history of the negotiations between
Israel and the surrounding Muslim Arabs
and why they all failed and what
happened and why they were rejected
which ultimately all comes back to you
because it's a jihad and drive them up
from where they drove you out does not
that's a principle from the Quran
chapter 2 verse 191
if non-muslims are ruling what is
considered to be Muslim land then the
Muslims have to drive them out and so
Israel will never have peace there and
they just have to be strong but in any
case and the Palestinian delusion I go
through to tremendous degree also in
here actually in the history of jihad
perhaps even more detailing here
the story of Haj Amin al-husseini Haj
Amin al-husseini was the Grand Mufti of
Jerusalem the Muslim leader of Jerusalem
and he lived in Berlin from 1941 to 1945
and he was friends with Himmler and
Eichmann and he met with Hitler they're
famous
there's famous photos and there's even a
video of him with Hitler and he actually
wrote to Hitler several times protesting
because the Nazis before they started
killing
the Jews they had they were they were
exiling them or they were allowing them
to leave and he was saying you can't do
this you can't let them come to the Holy
Land you you have to do something else
and it seems that he was one of the
people who got who encouraged them to go
with the idea of the mass killing rather
than exile and after the war when the
Nazis lost he went back to Egypt and he
started working against Israel and the
British in the French
they never prosecuted him even though he
was a Nazi war criminal who raised up an
SS division for the Nazis preached in
Arabic to the Muslim world telling them
they should support Hitler and quoting
the Quran to try to get them to do it
quoting the anti-semitic passages in the
Quran the Quran says the Jews are the
worst enemies of the Muslims chapter 5
verse 82 and there are many other
anti-semitic passages in the Quran so
Allah is saying he had to do was quote
the Quran to get the Muslims to think
Hitler was great and to favor Hitler so
yeah there's a great popularity of
Hitler in the Islamic world just
recently that was a story I had at G Hut
much about a restaurant in kurdistan
kurdistan is supposed to be full of
moderates and was our friends and it is
to tremendous degree but in Kurdistan
and Iraqi Kurdistan this guy had this
restaurant Hitler restaurant with the
swastika on the outside and all this
Hitler stuff is Hitler themed inside the
restaurant people loved it because they
love Hitler in my count Markov is a
perennial bestseller in Turkey and in
Egypt and what's really I think a shame
about this is that people don't realize
how this happened they don't realize
that there is a convergence between
Nazism and Islam because Islam is ante
a minute I actually debated a guy years
ago at UCLA who wrote a whole book
saying that the anti-semitism was never
in Islam and came into Islam with the
Nazis when Abu Saini was with the Nazis
in Berlin and there was never any
Islamic anti-semitism before that well
he didn't know his history this book
shows that there's anti-semitism all
through the Islamic history and that's
why the Nazis were attracted to them not
the other way the Quran is the perfect
word of the law delivered through the
angel Gabriel to Muhammad over 23 years
without any defect it's absolutely
perfect it was the mother of the book
the al-kitab was in paradise with Allah
for all eternity
and then delivered piece by piece to
Muhammad and that's the core know the
hadith are reports that's what the word
means report and they are reports of
Muhammad's words and deeds because the
Quran says chapter 33 verse 21 Muhammad
is the excellent example he is and
that's an absolute phrase that he is the
one you've got to follow and if he does
it it's right so Muhammad is the
excellent example how you gonna know
what Muhammad did he's only mentioned
four times by name in the Quran so you
go to the hadith which are reports of
his words and deeds you would need a
wheelbarrow to bring an old lady I have
30 volumes of hadith in my office
and I don't have all of it and the
hadith when they're considered authentic
are normative for Islamic laws and they
said Muhammad said this Muhammad said
that and so that becomes Islamic law
considering authentic cara + hadith
equals the Sun not the Sunnah is the
basis for Islamic law from which all
this is derived actually I was given a
little bit of a short answer I know it
seemed like a long answer but I do try
to keep these things short and I'll
never forget one time I was speaking in
Florida I think it was and I was given
one of these answers and then there was
a guy he was right about over there
and I don't mean to point in any of you
because obviously you weren't him and he
was doing and so I thought okay I will
try not to be so long so anyway this is
the deal
the hadith this is one of the big
reasons why I don't think Mohammed is a
historical figure because Muhammad is
supposed to have died in 632 but there's
nary a peep about what he was like until
the seven early 700 s the first
biography of Muhammad wasn't written
until about 7:30 a hundred years after
his death or more 750 125 years the
hadith collections come from the ninth
century
200 years after Muhammad and it's not
like this was an oral tradition because
oral tradition somebody would quote and
they would say you know Muhammad said X
& Y and somebody else would write it
down in something there's nothing for
the first 60 70 years of Islam and then
you start to get these stories about
Muhammad where did they come from people
made them up they didn't come from the
real Muhammad how do we know because
they're full of contradictions and that
is the clue as to what happened what
happened was once Muhammad became
established and that's a whole other
story how established as being the
Prophet then different groups of Muslims
would make up different stories about
what he said and did that justified what
they wanted so you see if this group
over here was in favor of one thing they
would make up the story says Muhammad
says we should do it our way and then
this rival group over here would say no
no Muhammad says we should do it this
way and then all these fake story even
Muslims will tell you that there are
these fake stories of Muhammad so
there's a whole science of a deed which
is devoted to determining which are the
authentic stories in which or not and
there's an elaborate process to do that
and I really will not be long-winded and
getting to that but the point is is that
Bukhari the the Imam who put together
the most reliable according to Islamic
sources the most reliable a deep
collection that is pretty much all of it
is normative for Islamic law Bukhari is
a ninth century Imam if the story goes
that he went around the Islamic world
and he collected three hundred thousand
hadith and then he figured out which
ones were authentic and published them
seven thousand of them
I have Bukhari it's nine volumes it's a
big book and it's seven thousand hadith
but that means that he decided that two
hundred ninety two thousand two deeth
were going to authentic worth it were
made up and I think he was right about
that
and he was also seven thousand off the
other were made up the others were made
up to maybe one one or two more yes sir
yes yeah yes September 11th 1883
oh yeah it's indefinite chapter five
verse 45 of the Quran says we ordained
for them a life for a life than I for an
eye a nose for a nose and ear for an ear
tooth for a tooth for all wounds like
for like now that's a total revenge
philosophy and you can say well that's
in the Bible to an eye for an eye into
tooth for tooth but then at the same
time in the New Testament there is turn
the other cheek and pray for those who
persecute you and love your enemies so
that's not the whole story but in the
Quran it is and on September 11 16 83
the Muslims were farther into Europe
than they ever got before and they were
besieging the city of Vienna in Austria
and the siege was broken and by
September 12th they were falling back
and so a lot of people think that Osama
bin Laden with a very long historical
memory decided on September 11th for the
attack as if to say now we're back and
we're picking up where we left off and
avenging that defeat I have this thought
and it's been going around I'm going to
know don't talk about this because when
I think about Obama he was like the
fracture of America to bring up
agitation again against you know this
whole people against people
to me as I'm hearing you speak was
starting to be that hand from within to
get the people from within to yeah and
he doesn't have to have been aware of
that to be that just like I keep
forgetting Martha in the season yeah
yeah um she doesn't know she's a tool
but she's a tool
she doesn't realize that she's being
used but she's being used and Obama was
a tool and was being used on a far
greater level now of course there's
always the possibility that he knew very
well what he was doing and I think there
is a case to be made for that to some
degree for example he was photographed
during the 2008 campaign reading a book
the post American world by Fareed
Zakaria the CNN commentator and Fareed
Zakaria is a very far leftist and in his
book the post American world he does
what the title suggests he says America
is the source of all our problems
because America is the world's lone
superpower and all the rest of the world
resents America and is jealous of
America and wants to bring America down
and that's exactly how we can fix it
this that if America is just as squalid
dirty and dangerous as everywhere else
then nobody will be trying to gun for us
there'll be peace and so what we need to
do is weaken America politically and
economically and societally and that
will bring peace to the world now
doesn't that sound like a what Obama did
for eight years oh yeah and he was
reading the book
schools and I'm really worried about our
children and I I don't remember the
interview but I remember going oh my god
this is a teacher speaking to these kids
in the way that she's speaking to them
so now we have an infiltration there I
mean oh yeah the schools are completely
taken over because nobody was paying
attention and the Council on Islamic
education which is another Muslim
Brotherhood linked group and other
Islamic groups they went to the textbook
manufacturers you know Mifflin and all
those people that make public school
textbooks and they said we will vet the
textbook material for you so that you
can make sure that it's not racist and
bigoted and that it's fair about Islam
and all the textbook manufacturers said
great okay and they let them and so now
pretty much every textbook in the United
States in terms of social studies and
history and whatever else that it's
related to that they are warmly positive
toward Islam practically proselytizing
for as long and the harshly critical of
Christianity and Judaism and I see this
all the time over the years of jihad
watch I've seen so many parents look
into their children's books and they're
shocked and they go complain to the
local school board and I'm all for that
that's great but it's a much bigger
problem we somehow bring to light you
can't push a rope try to press the
contradictions like somebody was asking
me earlier about how is it that these
feminist groups are all you know they
had Linda Sarsour with her good jab at
the head of the women's March although
she was just fired and they put in
another one with it
sacrebleu and they fired her too because
they keep getting noticed but the thing
is is that feminists are completely in
the tank about Islam and they will
criticize the mistreatment of women in
the Islamic world so I would say if you
have feminist friends you can ask for
press the contradiction and ask them why
is it that you don't care about these
women who are being killed for not
wearing the new jet wear where's your
concern for their rights are you really
serious about being in favor of women's
rights well then don't they count you
see things like that because there's a
whole lot that's a very rich field once
you start doing that well it's just
again you're opening my eyes and again
it's a very complicated intertwining
Road that yeah attempting to teach us
and doing better with others and well
I'm gonna take one more sorry I do that
to get to bed eventually yes it's early
[Music]
not as many as he shouldn't and I'm not
faulting for that he's under tremendous
pressure the president is certainly
aware of this problem his statements
make that clear but he's facing
entrenched opposition from the
bureaucracy that's in place in the FBI
in these agencies that is resisting him
and won't do this
and so his counter terror counter terror
program does speak about Islam and
allows agents to study Islamic texts in
order to understand the mindset of the
enemy which Obama had forbidden but that
he can put that in there that doesn't
mean they're going to do it you know
something I'm actually writing for the
first time in ten years I'm working on a
book now that's not about Islam or jihad
and it is a historical survey of all the
presidents of the United States and
rating them based on how good they were
for America and how much they put
America first which ought to be sort of
the common sense bar for whether guy is
good or not when he's the president of
the United States is he good for the
United States and the reason why I
mention it is because I'm going through
all this history I'm working up
historically and so I'm way back in the
early 19th century so far I just started
it and I'm reading about the spoils
system you may remember the spoils
system from social studies class or
whatever that it used to be that the
president when he became president would
fire everybody in
government practically and puttin his
own people and this was considered to be
it was called the spoils system because
it's the old phrase to the victor
belongs the spoils if you win then you
get the prize so this was a big fight in
all through the 19th century and finally
in the 1880s the Civil Service Act was
passed that was reforming the spoil
system actually destroying the spoils
system and putting in the idea that
these appointments in government jobs
would go to people who were qualify and
that would not depend on whether they
were with the president party or not and
everybody in every book that I am
reading to research the book I'm writing
everybody says this was great
and it ended a whole lot of corruption
and now we could get the best people
into government and they not thrown out
because they're in the wrong party ok
great
but my history is renegade histories you
might have expected going against the
conventional wisdom and one of the ways
that I'm doing that is I'm endorsing the
spoil system I'm saying we should bring
it back that what we see is something
the civil service reform people never
foresaw they never saw it at the coming
but it's here that we have an entrenched
bureaucracy of far-left democrats who
can't be removed and they hate the
president and they want to impede him at
everything he tries to do and i think we
should go back to the old way Trump
should be able to have his people in
positions of power and I'm saying this
for everyone all the way across the
board if we elect Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez in 2025 2024 then she should all
be able to put in her people and I would
be a disaster but I'm
I think the president ought to be able
to carry out his program and the Civil
Service Act makes that impossible
and the only now are we seeing how
dangerous it is and Andrew Jackson was
right the spoil system is great idea
array for Martin Van Buren again on
behalf of the solvent Republican
Committee I want to thank you for not be
intimidated not capitulate to the
progressive socialist Democrats in the
state you know it's always interesting
when when things get rough when times
get hard I look to my left I look to my
right I see who's there by my side and I
see who's in this room tonight I want to
thank each and every one of you and this
is the first of many speakers that are
going to be coming to Seoul and very
simply god bless each and every one of
you god bless america and thank you for
being here thank you